is there a moment as you look at your
career that you think
you almost gave up you wanted to just no
way no oh never
never I've got I think three signs in my
office
that tell me never to quit you quit
you're done doesn't matter what it is
I don't believe in quitting
[Music]
we have such a fascinating story
including you grew up on a dairy farm
and you've previously told Forbes that
growing up on this Farm you are not
allowed to milk a cow or drive a tractor
is that correct that's correct why is
that well I'm one of Nine Girls and my
father I just think felt that it was
safer he was always worried about us
kids girls being in the farm I think he
always wanted boys probably would have
stopped at two but went on to have nine
girls
he just had us do little little tasks
large tasks were for the men but you
learned hard work growing up on this
Farm I learned to work but I didn't I
didn't work around Machinery it's just
the way he was he just he was a man's
man and he didn't say that women
belonged in the house
but he also didn't encourage
getting into
business
like men
now you've also said that you're to grow
up very quickly what does that mean to
you
pregnant when I was just about 17 years
old
and
my parents encouraged me basically told
me you need to marry the father
of your son my baby at the time and I
did even though it was not a
it was puppy loving at love he was a
good man and it only lasted for three
years
that's when I really started to look at
a career and a career I had always
dreamed of having which was being in
business since I wasn't allowed to be on
the farm but to be engaged in something
that I wanted to and I always pictured
myself in blue suit having a nice car
and being independent so what was your
first job
oh my goodness I had a few little jobs I
worked at Parker Pen a little bit for
like three months and then the real job
that I really decided this was going to
be in my future is I started to get
involved in real estate
and before I was 21 years old and you
could actually sit in a model home you
could sell real estate off from a set of
prints so I got involved in that and
then eventually I got my real estate
license and I was a Playboy bunny
and I don't hide the fact it's a
glorified waitress and uh
it helped me to be able to pursue my
career which was real estate
was over there for about a year
and you know making enough money to
raise the Sun
[Music]
you and Ken were business partners and
life Partners but let's talk about
building a business together when did
ABC Supply begin and how Ken was a
roofer when I met him he had a roofing
Contracting firm that was local in
Madison and in in the Janesville area
and probably five years after I knew Ken
we started doing government work
for the military and so many nights with
big prints laying all over
trying to determine
what we're going to bid to get one of
those jobs
so we did that for quite a long time we
realized that the need in the our
industry the roofing industry that the
manufacturers ran the industry the
manufacturers each of them they were the
manufacturers of it but they were also
the distributor if you wanted that kind
of shingles you bought it from the
manufacturer there was no distribution
chain Across the Nation so there was
little pockets of where the products
were manufactured and that's you
generally bought
from the manufacturer that was in your
area as we were
being roofing contractors in the
military they would spec products that
you couldn't get in the areas where they
were building and you just start looking
at the need and over the course of five
ten years we realized that there needed
to be a distribution chain to be able to
offer to the customer us the contractor
the selection of various manufacturing
products Across the Nation and so we
pursued that
and finally put together a plan I
remember it took us like two years
to put together the plan on how do we
start
I started out by getting an apartment in
Beloit that is the city that really gave
us our start
Ken had lived in Janesville and uh
had a piece of real estate he called
himself an entrepreneur which was a word
that now is used in everyday language
for years and so that kind of halted his
banking in Janesville they asked Ken if
he knew what an entrepreneur was
and it was it was kind of a funny
conversation because he said it's a risk
taker and we don't do business with Risk
Takers and we started to make and was
blight savings back at the time and they
gave us a start
and so we we practiced on a wholesale
store that sold products for real estate
people just to see what it was like
to be a wholesale
let's call it a distributor we had a
little store in Beloit and from there we
decided we were ready a couple years
later and we opened up store one for ABC
Supply
with products that we brought in
shingles from different manufacturers
and uh we were in business for about
three years just buying up lumber yards
a couple here a couple there
and when we heard
that GAF was going to sell off
their roofing division of their
chemicals and Roofing they had two
divisions
and I know Ken and I were on vacation
and we flew home
and went up and met with JF and
sat with Sam Heyman who is the CEO of
family on the company
and
two young people that had never been to
New York and negotiated to buy 13 of
their stores
and we accomplished that it truly is the
city that made all the difference to Ken
and I and so I I just have found it very
rewarding to be able to help Beloit be
the city they always wanted to be
[Music]
if you look out one to five years what
do you want to be able to say about
Beloit and what you've done for the
community
it's already becoming this little Jewel
in southern Wisconsin because when you
start adding value to a community
everybody picks up their game
and it's it's wonderful these businesses
wouldn't be here if I hadn't invested in
the buildings you know the hotel that
was a
condo complex that we built and that's
all been sold down the building next to
it is the hotel the one across the
street is the hotel and the restaurants
so you when you have a community and
you're trying to make it Thrive you need
to see what the need of the community is
basically our goal Ken's in mind at the
time was to put life back in these
buildings
and that's what we've done here we call
this the spine it's about the middle of
what was the Beloit Corporation a a
major Factory they made all of the
paper making Machinery in the world was
here the largest and they
went broke had in foreclosure about 20
years ago and when did you buy it
about four years later
and it took a long time just to get it
all put together
and it was all empty it was really sad
everything from the very end of this
block all the way up to the only
building on Portland everything belonged
to the blade Corp and it was a
family-owned business and they sold it
to a company in Milwaukee and with one
one year
they put it into bankruptcy which was
just so sad for even the fact that the
company had closed it had never come
back after the recession
[Music]
you've been smart with your Acquisitions
I want to jump ahead I think that was a
Savvy strategy you employed during the
2008 financial crisis obviously not a
good time for housing the housing market
the market that depends on the goods
that that you sell can you talk about
what you did then because you have
referred to it as the biggest risk
you've ever taken
well I lost my husband in seven
but um you could feel that recession
coming on
it was it was very scary
very very scary so it really became
evident that we were in a recession in
late of 2008 2009.
we had about 250 locations at that time
that we'd acquired over the course of my
husband we started when Ken was 40 I was
33. a lot of people think well you just
started business and
you started ABC no it didn't work like
that it was years of trying other
businesses and actually developing
business we had and still have some of
them
but the recession was um we just
buckle down and uh and did what you do
in a recession you know you cut back on
this Quebec on that
but um
there was a acquisition that came
available
and it was Radco
and there was no way
I could oversee that acquisition at that
time
it was a large company not as large as
we were at that time
but I had to take on a partner
an investment partner and I had to give
up 40 some percent of my shares
we've always owned everything we owned
it we're a sub s
took proud in owning and being to
operate our companies but this one was
one that I knew that I knew the company
and it had to be done and it it really
is painful to give a give up control and
to bring in investment bankers
but it we structured that if I could
give them the return like they always
want to return within five years
I would buy my shares back
did you buy your shares back yes
we bought them back in three three and a
half years and I still get shippers
right now because I felt I had risked
the company that I wanted my children to
run when we're not here you know it's
it's not a company that's ever going to
be for sale it's a strong company we
changed the industry the whole nation
now is has a distributor in between you
can buy any product any place in the
nation manufacturers aren't running you
know the regional
distribution of materials and it makes
the choice
and the contract everything better it
really really was an amazing thing that
we did by starting out with two stores
and three stores and distributing
various manufactured products and it's
what made ABC so powerful but to make
that acquisition at that time during a
recession
was I was felt like I was risking it all
but I knew that I knew that it was a
good company we were buying and has
proven to be one of the best
Acquisitions we ever did but you can't
see into the future
you can't see that far into the future
so it was it was it was difficult but
great team I have I have a great team
had a great team then
and everybody believed that we could get
it done and I you have to trust trust
your experts within the companies that
we have and we did it
you have an incubator around here we
have an incubator that's on the other
side correct what are the companies that
you incubate what are you oh any
companies that come here and want space
and they share you know in common
support staff things like that but we're
we're very much into
um
innovation
I mean that really is what we're about
whether there's a a actual building that
does that or if we just in our personal
selves get involved in bringing business
to town economic growth is what makes
buildings survive depending on the tech
company or there's a battery company
that makes batteries uh different
batteries than we're having today blue
battery is called we've invested in that
these are Innovation entrepreneurial
ideas that we feel it's not just an idea
they've usually taken it to one step
where they actually have you know
initiated the product everybody's got an
idea you've got to First is it real is
it a real idea as
an entrepreneur as an owner what do you
look for in an acquisition and how do
you know it's the right fit when you do
Acquisitions you learn the word
diligence because you've got to look
under the covers more than once and see
what you're buying
to make sure that it makes Financial
sense and is there really a need or
should we move somewhere else
[Music]
if you had to summarize what has made
the company so successful we've talked
about acquisition what do you think the
secret to your success has been
hiring great people surrounding myself
with people of good integrity
knowing knowing the need of the
different businesses you know that I've
invested in you know we did it because
we knew there was a need in the industry
but we also knew that we had to build
the best company
we're the best people we could find
and we did
we're the best company in America I
think because of the people that we that
make it up
people always make the difference they
make all the difference in the world
you and Ken seem to have a real true
partnership in every sense of the word
and I recognize that but I'm also
curious because this business
has so many elements to it and you've
also made investments in Beloit what's
your baby what's Diane's best idea
school you know you've got to have a
future and we we build futures for
children over there there's a golf lab
there's a Career Tech because we do a
lot of education for the children after
school that don't belong to the TLA
school but there's like 800 children
that come here over the course of the
year
it's all about learning careers and Tech
there's a lot of tech also being taught
it's going to need a little bit of
funding because Charter Schools aren't
welcome in Wisconsin and so we we only
get about two-thirds of what public
schools get and we educate the same
children only
so we have to continue to feed that
generally you can you figure out what
you're going to put into something and
at least Break Even but the school
wasn't so I'm hoping that the public
school will revisit what they're
teaching and get the other 5 600 kids in
Beloit truly educated to have a quality
life
our Public School System across the
nation has major problems especially in
Beloit they've suffered
in the school system
the numbers that children are graduating
and their ability to get on with their
life
it's very difficult very difficult
so it got to the point that the only way
that we could really help
is to put competition
in the city and to actually start a
school build a school
and embrace educating the children so
that they don't just graduate but they
graduate
with with knowledge
and we're doing that we're one year old
in math we doubled what they had learned
200 percent in one year the mission for
our school is that you will graduate and
you will already know a career maybe
nursing because we do a lot of
vocational training it's fabulous what
we're doing there with kids so with that
said
um
I'm really proud
what did you want to be when you grew up
I mean we're talking here for the 50
over 50 and I love asking people did you
ever imagine your over 50 career when
you were a teen or in your 20s I
I tell this story when I
as I remember the day I stood at the
window in The Farmhouse
and thought I don't want to be a farmer
I don't want to marry a farmer
I was 10. and I dreamed about wearing
that blue suit
and go into the city I lived in Osseo
Wisconsin
I the city I wanted to go to was
Minneapolis because it was the biggest
city close by and my two older sisters
one was working up there already I knew
what I didn't want to do
you do dream if you don't dream you
don't have a goal you don't know where
you're going to go
you have to you have to think about your
future and I think thinking about your
future the Younger You Are
the more you start looking at at those
careers you just notice what's going on
in life
now I'm facing oh life life on this
Earth is
I I'm not done yeah you know that's the
most frustrating part I think of getting
old is golly there's still so much
so much to do
what do you want to do
more
more education more for the school
more for the people that have helped me
you know just to give back in many ways
we had to take down a building that was
dry rotted it was dangerous it had to
come down right in the middle of the
block so it's built like it was there
forever
and on the building my name and I didn't
know that until Rob brought me down he
goes I want to show you something I know
you're not going to be happy and he goes
and it's like Rob
because I didn't do it for you
I did it for your grandkids because
you're not here to tell them and so I
did that for your grandkids to see your
name up there and what you've done for
Beloit so that's the only place that
says Diane why don't you want your name
anywhere else I don't need it there I
just don't need that's something I don't
need I know some people need that
recognition I just I'm happy seeing the
city come back my life is so exciting
when it comes to Growing it's what it
does it brings people and gives them
purpose and and pleasure
I guess my big hope um you know I'm old
I've had a blessed life
blessed life and I wanted to be in
business I'm in business and I know my
children will pick up when I leave
my son is my uh CEO at my holding
company and he oversees the 16 companies
that we oversee and so he's learning
that and I'm comfortable in saying I can
you know pass the wand to my kids and
they love the city too I'm independent
and I'm I'm proud of what I I work for
and I earn
and I still have those same values I
pass it on to my children they've all
worked my grandchildren I get asked all
the time why do you still go to work
you're ancient
my kids and and you know like Mom you
know why are you still going to work
you're 75 years old
it's like I said I'm healthy I love what
I do I'm still growing companies
why would I
why would I quit I don't give advice
usually people have to figure things out
themselves but I I tell my children just
[Music]
you know if you want to do that just do
it I just think there's a lot you can
learn in life and I have learned a lot I
didn't go to college I had to learn I
had to learn what I know
you know whether it be hard knocks or by
mistake
but you're learning you carry that that
knowledge with you
I know there's more I can do I just you
know like everybody the clock is ticking
I gotta hurry up and get it done
so I'm I'm working at it
[Music]